travers cinq ans que je bosse sur final
cut et encore aujourd'hui je découvre
des trucs mais deux tarés et on en parle
bien évidemment mais juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver aujourd'hui pour une
nouvelle vidéo
alors je sais que vous êtes très friande
astuces sur final cut et aujourd'hui je
vous avoue je vous propose un truc qui
moi m'a complètement fait halluciner
parce que ça m'a fait gagner un temps
monstreux vous allez voir c'est un
groupe d'astuces qui vont vous faire
gagner un temps hallucinant dans vos
montages mais juste avant de commencer
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour les
gens qui ont acheté ma formation puisque
dans les jours qui viennent va y avoir
de nouveaux modules une quinzaine de
nouveaux modules notamment sur
l'étalonnage et plein d'autres choses
assez sympa et si vous avez déjà acheté
la formation et ben c'est nouveau module
ils seront totalement gratuits ils
seront en plus de ce que vous avez déjà
y'a rien à racheter mais si vous ne
l'avez pas encore acheté ben j'ai une
bonne nouvelle aussi puisque cette
formation pour apprendre toutes les
bases sur final cut une formation dans
laquelle je vous montre tout mon one flo
de travail eh ben elle est en promo pour
quelques jours donc je vous mets le lien
en descriptions n'hésitez pas à aller
faire un tour vous allez voir ça vaut
vraiment cool et super note enfin voila
c'était la petite parenthèse formation
maintenant on rentre dans le vif du
sujet on va aller voir ses astuces de
ouf
dans final cut à la première chose à
faire pour développer toutes ses astuces
et tout ce qu'on va voir ici c'est
d'aller voir le gestionnaire de
raccourcis clavier dans final cut vous
avez une option si vous faites option
commandes cas qui va nous à des
châtiments tous les raccourcis possibles
et imaginables de final cut tout ce qui
y est par défaut et le truc cool c'est
qu'on va pouvoir créer nos propres
raccourcis parce que en fouillant un
petit peu je me suis rendu compte qu'il
y avait des fonctions qui soit n'avait
pas de raccourci donc c'était les
fonctions qu'il fallait aller chercher
dans les menus ou alors des raccourcis
relativement complexe avec trois touches
par exemple et ce qui est super cool
c'est qu'on va donc pouvoir créer notre
propre clavier alors pouvez voir ici on
a le clavier par défaut et un clavier
ici que moi j'ai créé et qui s'appelle
custom qui bordent
donc ça veut dire que vous pouvez faire
toutes vos modifications mais vous fait
une boulette un que vous remplacez un
raccourci important par un autre et bien
vous pouvez repartir sur le clavier par
défaut ou
supprimer le clavier customiser et en
refaire un autre après donc à rien de
dramatique vous pouvez explorer autant
que vous voulez ici vous avez accès aux
commandes classés par catégorie on
pouvait avoir un peu tout et pouvez
chercher plus facilement dans les effets
dans les fenêtres etc etc
vous pouvez avoir aussi toutes les
commandes pouvez faire défiler comme ça
si vous voyez quelque chose qui vous
interpelle et vous dites à ce raccourci
je le connaissais pas ou ce raccourci je
le custom minerai bien et pour rajouter
un raccourci c'est très simple vous le
sélectionné dans la liste des commandes
ici vous avez sélectionné une touche à
laquelle vous voulez la signer ici vous
avez par exemple j'ai choisi la touche
est ce si vous la mettez ici sur aucune
ça veut dire que juste la touche s va
faire cette action ici commandes non
commande est ce chiffre s option s etc
etc contrôle s et toutes les
combinaisons possibles avec la touche
est-ce donc il suffit de prendre de
faire glisser et c'est bon si vous
voulez retirer une fonction il suffit de
l'apprendre et de la faire glisser à
l'extérieur et de lâcher le curseur en
parlant de la touche est ce je vais vous
montrer le premier raccourci que j'ai
fait alors le premier que j'ai utilisé
avec cette méthode là c'est tout
simplement d'assigner à la touche
est ce la fonction de couper ici j'ai un
blanc je coupe je coupe je supprime
alors avant ça j'aurai du faire soi
comment deux baies commandes b supprimer
ou alors passer sur l'outil rasoir avec
la touche b couper ici couper la
repasser sur le tissu élections est
supprimée bon vous allez me dire c'est
une petite subtilité c'est pas forcément
fou mais avec la fonction qui arrive
derrière vous allez voir donc je que au
début et je vais aller me placer à la
fin et j'ai assigné à la touche q la
fonction élaguer jusqu'à la tête de
lecture et la cij appuie dessus
en fait ça m'a fait deux actions saha
que tu es et ce à renier toute la partie
entre le coeur et la tête de lecture ici
que j'ai déplacé
hélas le temps a gagné il est fou par
exemple si je vais enlever tous ces
blancs bien est-ce que je vais me mettre
un autre endroit j'ai un blanc est ce qu
et ça pour ceux qui font ce genre de
montage et qui ont des blancs a coupé
comme ça vous savez à quel point une
action de gagner sur tout un tas de
répétition d'action comme ça c'est un
temps monstrueux de gagner alors
raccourci que j'ai rajouté ici pareil
qui n'a pas de raccourci de base qui est
une fonctionnalité qu'il faut aller
chercher c'est pour faire des ralentis
normalement pour faire un ralenti pour
mettre la vitesse automatique
on a filmé à 100 images par seconde
ralentir quatre fois il faut aller ici
dans ce petit onglet là il faut cliquer
sur vitesses automatique ici vous voyez
il ya un raccourci mais c'est moi qui
l'ait rajouter à la base il y en avait
pas donc tout simplement le clic sur mon
fichier je sais qu'il est enregistré en
sans images par seconde et j'appuie sur
la touche y est j'ai mon ralenti voilà
c'est ça c'est juste incroyable
plutôt que d'aller chercher dans ce menu
là je comprends pas d'ailleurs qui est
pas une touche dédiée de base pour faire
ce genre de truc là me remerciez pas
c'est cadeau ensuite je me suis dit mais
tiens qu'est-ce que je fais très souvent
qui me prend un petit peu de temps et
bien ce que je fais souvent c'est que
une fois que j'ai fait mon montage je
veux faire ma colo donc j'ajoute un
calque d'ajustement est normalement pour
un calque il faut aller ici dans les
titres adjustment meilleur angle calq et
le faire glisser ici voilà donc il ya
quand même trois quatre clics 1 alors ce
que j'ai fait ici j'ai assigné au touch
control t
la commande a ajouté un titre par défaut
et par défaut c'était pas celui-là
sauf que je suis allé dans mes titres
j'ai pris mon agent payeur un clic droit
dessus et définir comme titre par défaut
qui fait que maintenant en faisant cette
commande option tm un boum j'ai mon
adjoint flyers qui arrive directement
sur ma timeline j'ai plus qu'à les tirs
et à la longueur que je veux et c'est
terminé et que j'étais tellement content
d'avoir trouvé ça que je me suis dit
tiens si on ajouté quelque chose d'autre
est ce que par exemple quand je fais ce
genre de montage rapide j'ai pas une
lutte que j'ai déjà mises en place comme
dans mon pack de lutte qui se situe dans
la description est ce que j'ai pas déjà
une lutte que j'ai préparé exprès pour
ce genre de vidéos que je pourrai
assigné geyrhalter raccourci options ou
pour me mettre un effet par défaut qui
est l'effet lutte personnalisé pour
mettre un effet par défaut c'est pareil
on va dans le visualisant des faits ici
on faire un clic droit et on peut
cliquer comme définir comme effets vidéo
par défaut est alors j'ai aussi un petit
peu à quai le truc c'est à dire que je
me suis dit j'aimerais bien quand même
pouvoir m
un texte un titre par défaut aussi mais
du coup mon adjointe d'ailleurs me
prendrait la place c'est pas d'âme
je suis allé dans mes titres toujours
j'ai pris le titre de base qui est
personnalisé voilà celui ci j'ai fait un
clic droit et je les définit comme tiers
inférieur par défaut avec le raccourci
contrôle shift t et toutes ses astuces
là tous ces raccourcis
ça fait gagner un temps de malades alors
là c'est certain si ça vous fait pas
gagner de temps je sais pas ce que ça
fait d'ailleurs si ça vous a plu vous
pouvez bien entendu mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous avez
d'autres astuces si vous voulez nous
partager vos raccourcis mettez les en
commentaire parce que ça peut aider tout
le monde et il ya peut-être des choses
auxquelles j'ai pas pensé moi et puis
moi je vous dis les amis comme
d'habitude rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo sur la
formation n'a quand même actuellement
une note moyenne de 4,81 sur cinq
quand même assez cool et des
commentaires trop cool voilà moi je dis
ça elle en prob aussi vous l'avez pas
acheter si vous avez final cut fall que
vous pouvez télécharger gratuitement
pendant 90 jours pour tester
moi je dis ça se tente